I'll talk about Bernie Sanders in a little
bit.
But very, very soon after Bernie's endorsement
of 20 20 Democratic presidential nominee Joe
Biden, former President Barack Obama has now
endorsed former V.P.
Joe Biden.
There are people saying Obama should have
gotten involved earlier.
I think it was pretty clear Obama was never
going to endorse Bernie.
And in the end, the guy Obama would likely
have endorsed one anyway.
So the conversation about is Obama late seems
practically speaking, irrelevant.
But let's take a look to just a little bit
of Barack Obama's statement yesterday.
I believe it was a 12 minute statement in
total.
We'll look about look at about a minute and
a half here.
I'm so proud to endorse Joe Biden for president
of the United States.
Choosing Joe to be my vise president was one
of the best decisions I ever made.
And it became a close friend.
And I believe Joe has all the qualities we
need in a president right now.
He's someone whose own life has taught him
how to persevere, how to bounce back when
you've been knocked down.
When Joe talks with parents who've lost their
jobs, we hear the son of a man who once knew
the pain of having to tell his children that
he'd lost his.
When Joe talks about opportunity for our kids,
we hear the young father who took the train
home each night so he could tuck his children
into bed.
And we hear the influence of Jill, a lifelong
teacher.
When Joe talks to families who've lost a hero,
we hear another parent of an American veteran,
a kindred spirit, somebody whose faith has
endured the hardest loss there is.
That's Joe.
Through all his trials, he's never once forgotten
the values or the moral fiber that his parents
passed on to him.
And that made him who he is.
That's what steals his faith in God, in America
and in all of us, certainly filled with lots
of political speak.
That to me, it it speaks to me very, very
little.
It doesn't speak to me very strongly for lack
of a better term.
But Barack Obama's involvement is potentially
very important here.
Whatever you think about Barack Obama or Joe
Biden.
A highly involved Barack Obama improves the
chances that Donald Trump is defeated.
You might remember back in 2008, George W.
Bush was very unpopular and was almost completely
missing from the campaign trail in support
of the Republican nominee.
John McCain just didn't make sense.
It was possibly going to hurt John McCain
to have George W. Bush heavily involved in
the 2008 Republican campaign for the presidency.
Ultimately, McCain lost anyway to Barack Obama.
In this case, it's very, very different.
If and when the real campaigning is able to
get going and this will depend on the virus,
of course, there may be a window there between,
you know, early July through late September
or maybe before Wave 2 is likely to hit where
there will be some real campaigning.
I believe it's a very good thing for Joe Biden,
for Barack Obama to be right there with them.
And for better or worse, Obama there with
Biden will create the contrast in people's
minds of Trump versus what things were like
under Barack Obama.
Now, I want to be really clear about what
I mean by that.
Barack Obama was wrong on many issues, right?
The Obama administration's dealing with whistleblowers
was not good.
The Obama administration's drone warfare policy
was not good way we could go on and on.
But the U.S. was respected as an adult, was
leading us back then because we had an adult
leading us and with the country shut down.
It's very difficult to gain any momentum if
you're Joe Biden.
Trump is making bad decisions daily with coronavirus,
but sadly, many of his followers seem to fall
more and more in love with Trump, the worse
his decisions on coronavirus are.
Some even see Trump as decisive and strong
and powerful in the context of virus.
So Biden needs to do something to get attention
and start building momentum.
OK, I guess eventually there are going to
be debates.
We don't know exactly what the format will
be again because of the virus.
But one way to maybe start building momentum
to a small degree would be to see Barack Obama's
increased involvement.
Barack Obama, of course, much more powerful
on social media than Joe Biden.
And I've said it before and I've said it many
times.
The choice is just really clear.
And there are people on Twitter talking about
how do you choose between two Nazis?
Don't you just opt out?
This is not a choice between two Nazis.
This is a choice between a lunatic authoritarian
who is in way over his head, cares only about
himself and whose decisions are leading to
more corona virus deaths than were necessary
or than what the minimum could have otherwise
been.
That's one option.
The other option is a center left diplomat
with decades of experience who is less progressive
than I would like the president to be.
The courts alone are enough to show us the
importance of voting for Biden.
When you compare Biden and Trump on the environment,
Biden is way better when you compare Biden
and Trump on regulating business.
Biden's better.
Biden's tax plan is better.
Biden's health insurance plan is better.
Biden's better on LGBT rights.
Biden's better on abortion.
And on and on and on.
There's just no comparison.
I don't need Joe to come beg for my vote.
I know that there's a lot of Bernie supporters
saying Joe needs to come get my vote, but
Joe needs to put out a policy platform which
we can analyze like adults and make decisions
about.
I don't need to try to get anybody's attention
by claiming, you know, I might stay home,
I might do it or I might write in somebody
else.
It's not a blank check to the Democratic Party.
I'm not even a Democrat.
It's that I've looked at the policy platforms
and Biden's the clear better choice.
Biden isn't entitled to anything.
The DNC is not entitled to anything.
I don't vote blue no matter who.
I'm not a Democrat.
I'm looking at the candidates.
It's clear which one is better.
That's all this is now.
In the meantime, a former Republican congressman,
Justin Amash, who left the Republican Party
and became an independent, Justin Amash, is
reportedly thinking about running as an independent.
This would be tremendously useful to Joe Biden
and potentially damaging to Donald Trump.
Amash, as a longtime Republican, would likely
pull way more Republican votes than he polls
Democratic votes.
And being from Michigan, which could end up
being a very important state in the twenty,
twenty November election.
Michigan's governor even being sort of thrown
around as a possible running mate for Joe
Biden.
It could be a absolutely delightful thing
and could singlehandedly hand Michigan to
Joe Biden.
Just a rumor that Justin Amash is thinking
about that.
I say we encourage him
to run.
I think
it's a very, very good idea.